This can be a hard problem to think about, I got the axis wrong myself when I
was first making up this quiz, drawing sketches helps. Remember that a vector
rotating around an axis forms a circle. The cylinders axis on the y axis and the
final axis thru the corner of the cube define a circle whose center is at the
origin. If you think about continuing this arc the whole way, it becomes pretty
clear you're cutting the cube in half diagonally when viewed from above. We can
also see that the axis through this circle is going to point in this direction
or the opposite direction in order to be perpendicular to this slice. Since the
y axis is in this slicing plane, there won't be any y component in the
coordinates for the axis of rotation itself. So this axis must be either x
positive and z negative or x negative and z positive. For this reason the second
answer is correct. Negative x z is the axis. There can only be one plane that
contains the circle and there is only one axis direction or its opposite
direction that is perpendicular to this plane. Therefore there is only one axis
of rotation that will take us from our starting position to the corner of the
cube. So we can rule out all three of the other answers.